all right guys
bang bang i have the mayor of my oh just
kidding i've deli in here
what's up prince of miami the prince of
miami exactly
uh let's get started talking about space
uh varda
is a company that you co-founded uh
while working at founders fund
what is going on in space like why do
you want to do this
i've been thinking about space since
like i don't know i was a kid maybe like
2007
8 like you know freshman year of high
school and was just like fascinated with
this world of like the commercialization
of space like the end of the day the
apollo era was like super cool but it
was government dollars and government
dollars are limited they can't grow
exponentially uh but it was like super
cool to see i've been tracking spacex
since like the very first launch
i was like oh my god like if they figure
out how to pull off a commercial rocket
that makes it to the commercial
satellites and all these other things
are like so much more viable
um and so i've been tracking it for like
sort of years and years and then finally
maybe in like
2016 i started being like okay i need to
start considering like
not just having this is like a hobby
where i'm like reading books and like
watching the launches like
i gotta start to do this like actually
professionally um and so that was part
of why i actually joined venture was
cause like
i found it to be the best way to sort of
do it earlier on in my career cause like
i basically thought there were a couple
different paths one i had a bunch of
friends from mit that actually
went to like work at spacex right some
of them you know still work there
but i'm like i'm a pretty good engineer
i don't know if i want to be like an
engineer like 90
of the day like what i like is like i
can do the engineering plus business
plus a little marketing storytelling
like i kind of like a diverse set of
like
you know skill sets that like i work on
so i didn't want to do that the other
path that i thought was the only
possible option was like you do the like
chamath jurvidson
elon approach i like make it big in like
regular tech and then you get to do
space stuff
but i was like man that path to you like
is gonna take too long and so that was
where like sort of path three
sort of showed itself to me where i was
like oh the world of venture allows me
to like actually kind of learn
about space because venture is one of
the only jobs in the valley where like i
feel you actually get paid to like learn
whatever you kind of want to learn
and so six months into like this role at
coastal ventures which was originally
supposed to be like a
one-year stand i was just supposed to
like you know figure out how to co-found
a company and like kind of was like
happy ir
half chief of staff type thing i
actually sourced a space company and i
was like oh [ __ ] i can do the space
stuff today
and so it's kind of this like whole like
i don't know like left turn in my life
where i was like okay
screw the being in the founder thing i'm
going to do the venture thing really
leaning into this and i'm going to make
sure that one of my focus areas is just
like i'm going to keep doing space and
so invested in that first base company
started spending a ton of time going to
like space conferences meeting everybody
and like when you see it from afar it
feels like a you know i'm sure you know
crypto and other industries the same way
where it's like
it feels like there's a ton going on
blah blah but once you get into it it's
like
actually there's like you know probably
20 companies that have raised north of
15 million dollars
that represent basically the entire
commercial space industry and i
literally just met basically every ceo
except you know elon um and got to know
all of them and like you start to
understand okay like how do satellites
get sent
what are rockets made out of what are
the components what's the supply chain
how do you do all this
and you actually start to realize okay
here are like the possible sort of
angles of attack and like
potential other ideas and you know
things you could work on and that's kind
of eventually how varda came about
but the thing that i kept tracking was
like you know a lot of the like let's
say like you know mobile industry
and a lot of like you know sas was
enabled by aws you know getting really
really cheap in you know 2006 2007
and i always described that like elon
with spacex is basically the equivalent
of
aws where this asset that used to be
extremely expensive
only accessible to government like what
is the pain in the ass eye rocket
launches
is now like dude you can book on
spacex's website
a 200 kilogram satellite you can send it
up for a million bucks
literally just like there's like an
e-commerce float like they literally
like you click through
for sure you gotta like talk to a sales
dude to like you know submit the wire
but like you do like a little prepayment
and like entirely digitally right
um and then like once that's wild that's
wild like
one day it'll be like full online like
we're not that far away from like
literally like you literally don't have
to talk to anybody there's still a lot
of like hard engineering that has to go
into like
right now when you like book a spacex
launch you still work like it's not like
you just talk to the sales guys like
the engineers over there they have to
like integrate your satellite into it
but like there's a lot of companies
working on
okay how do we standardize this make it
so that like you know you can literally
just do this purely purely digitally
and so that's what i started to track
and got me really excited about varda
where i was like okay this
aws like cost i launch costs are now
cheap enough where
it's not just satellites that are now
economical space manufacturing is
economical okay so what is space
manufacturing that's the whole point of
varda is to do space manufacturing so
what is that
yeah so i described it like we're doing
space manufacturing for earth there's a
lot of people that think about space
manufacturing in space so it's like
building stuff in space or doing like
lunar ice mining stuff like that like
that's that's cool
but that stuff's like sci-fi like a
venture capitalist can't really back
that like there's cool government
projects going on but that stuff is
again very small dollars
versus what we're doing is we're
building materials in space for use
back here on earth which means there's
earth-sized markets
very large commercial markets and so
there's already been a ton of research
done on the iss over the past literally
like 15 years
that has showed everything from you know
cancer drugs like amgen and eli lilly
have shown that they have better yields
of their cancer drugs
when they manufacture them in
microgravity uh there's been human
organs that have been printed in space
basically the way you can think about is
if you try to print
a human organ on earth it like flops
over because of gravity versus if you're
in zero g you can kind of keep printing
it
and you can see you can print a really
complex organ there are semiconductors
that have been shown fiber optic cables
basically a ton of materials that have
been shown up there and so in early 2020
actually before starting varda
i went and talked to all these
researchers that had done this type of
microgravity stuff and i was like great
super cool you guys have done this on
the iss but the iss is never going to be
like a commercial factory nasa's not
going to allow a bunch of [ __ ] like
you know line workers up there
we got to do this independently of the
iss they're all like yes we need to do
it independently i'm like great can i
give you money to do that they're like
no
i was like well why the [ __ ] not they're
like well we don't know how to go
independent of the iss like we're
researchers that rely on nasa for
getting up there running our like
research and then coming back down
so right now basically you can uh kind
of the workflow would be i want to run a
test
in space in microgravity for let's say
fiber optic cable
app development and so what i do is i
get all my materials
i book it on spacex rocket they launch
uh
my [ __ ] gets to the iss then somebody
who's on the iss
is given instructions essentially do by
test
send it back and when a rocket comes
back then
uh i get my results and like just do
that over and over and over again
obviously there's limitations around how
much can go on the rocket how many
people are on the iss what's the
complexity what's their knowledge et
cetera
exactly i mean like uh from start to
finish that whole process you talked
about
takes on average four years um the
largest thing
you can send up is roughly the size of
like a glove box so really limited like
total volume
and then there's extreme limitations on
like for example in a lot of fiber
optics there's a toxic chemical that you
want to coat the fiber optic with that
protects it at the end of the process
no [ __ ] way is now it's going to let
you put that toxic chemical in the iss
if that thing gets out like you're
potentially killing astronauts
so there's like severe limitations on
the processes the size
how long it takes if you want to iterate
on that process you're like
sending it up and then four years later
you're gonna iterate on the process once
again and so it just takes way way too
long
and so our whole idea was like okay how
would we do this independent of the iss
great we can still get up there via
spacex rocket lab you know because they
can just send the rockets and you can
you don't have to go to the iss you can
go to any destinations exactly you can
go wherever you want to so that part
still stays the same but now okay we got
to go independent of the iss that means
now we got to power ourselves
communicate with ourselves
that part actually also pretty easy
because look at starlink look at you
know planet labs they they power
satellites up there they communicate
with them
they have batteries up there okay so
that part's pretty easy the actual glove
block it's like okay well now we're
gonna take that same glove box that
fiber optic unit that you know whatever
or you know human organs that people are
making
take that same thing now we can go a lot
bigger now we can put that toxic
chemical in there now we can go a lot
hotter now we can bring more materials
up there
so that part if anything is like easier
in some ways than it was on the isas
the only like wrinkle is the iss is
pressurized in atmosphere
uh versus uh to keep it really low cost
we're putting everything in vacuum
explain the engineering difference yeah
so in atmosphere um
the biggest thing is actually the like
thermal environment um so you know right
now i'm in this room right my body is
generating heat and it's getting moved
away from me from the like cold air
that's basically around me and that's
how most things get cooled down in
manufacturing processes so you have like
a you know a really hot semiconductor
the way that it cools off on a typical
like you know intel manufacturing line
is the air around it basically just
cools it down uh
in vacuum there's no air and so if
something gets hot it just stays hot
and so what you have to do is you have
to use these what are called like
radiative
cooling tubes and then the way that they
basically work is like
the little like you know semiconductor
glows a little bit red when it gets too
hot
the radiated cooling tube absorbs that
and then it actually sends it out to
these like little wires that are on the
outside of the satellite that are
basically made
to glow extra red when they get hot and
that glowing of that red light is the
only way you actually quote
cool down and so that's the really hard
part is basically cooling down
is really hard when there's no
atmosphere so basically what you're
doing is
uh you're taking the same principle of
bring something here to cool this down
the difference is that you're doing it
in a much more kind of thoughtful
intentional way versus just allowing the
air around it
exactly exactly so that's the maybe
tricky part but other than that
everything in some ways is much easier
when you leave the iss because you can
go bigger
more materials more chemicals um the iss
you know doesn't have the same or
you don't have the limitations from the
iss but then the part that all these
researchers were really scared of is
okay we finished those materials
got to bring them back down to earth
that's what everybody's really scared of
because the counter-intuitive thing
is uh right now it's actually quite easy
to get up to space uh what we do is we
take a rocket we get it out of the
atmosphere
and then we go really really fast right
and that's how we actually orbit and the
hard part for a rocket isn't getting out
of the atmosphere like
that's only like you know the first like
whatever 120 seconds of the flight
the hard part is like then they're going
really really fast so that you stay in
orbit rather than just
coming back down so when you think about
it is when you're coming back
you're going really fast and like yeah
you could like send a whole rocket up
there
slow yourself down and then hit the
atmosphere but that's really inefficient
the much better way to do it is just
come into the atmosphere really [ __ ]
fast and use the atmosphere to slow you
down
that process of reentry has never really
been done by commercial organizations
other than spacex with their dragon
program right so whenever you see the
astronauts coming back
the like trickiest part of that whole
journey is when they come back
going really really fast the atmosphere
same thing with the apollo era days
um that's like the most you know
dangerous part for the astronauts when
they're coming back how fast are they
going when they're re-entering you're
going like
uh man i hope any space engineer reading
this doesn't like correct me on this but
i think 14
000 kilometers per second so you're
talking like real real fast
like yeah multiple g forces in terms to
give you a sense of like uh so you know
we take these materials yes you go
through roughly eight g's at the peak um
so
um in our type of reactor because we're
not taking back humans so the reason
that like sort of our vehicle in some
ways is much simpler is like
we are just taking back some like raw
materials we don't have to take back a
bunch of humans and so i sometimes
describe like
our thing that we're using to bring down
the materials is like a you know
delivery van
versus like the spacex dragon vehicle
it's like a gold-plated limousine with
like great ac
and soft seats for the astronauts you
know what i mean that thing cost a
hundred million
we're making something for like 100k to
bring back our materials so
i send up materials yep there's a
satellite or a vehicle there
and then i have to get back what is the
process to get the materials off of
the thing that goes up into the actual
like testing or manufacturing
uh facility and then how do i get it
back is that all robotic
yeah so the first time we're actually
just sending everything up already
pre-connected
in the future for sure we'll be doing
docking and moving around but the first
time we actually send the like satellite
looking thing
the factory looking thing and what we
call the reentry capsule we actually
just send that all connected already so
basically it's like already ready to go
in the future for sure for a variety of
reasons that actually gets much more
economical to not send it up all
together but to do sort of that
demonstration mission
we're sending it all up together and
basically literally the raw materials
passed from the factory into that like
re-entry module
the reentry module comes back in but
like to give you a sense so like you
know we actually
uh you know have to uh we have regulated
by the faa because like we're
re-entering over air space
um if we like miss uh you know the
atmosphere even literally by like three
or four seconds
you're talking about like rather than
like landing in the united states you're
like accidentally like landing in like
europe
and so you're going so so fast that like
you have to be extremely precise about
like
where you re-enter and so a lot of the
problem is like convincing the fva hey
we're gonna make sure to do a very sort
of like controlled reentry
um in a very sort of tight area such
that we don't accidentally like you know
land in somebody's house and like kill
them
is this the whole it was a chinese
rocket or something that was like coming
back and
people were like oh it could land in
asia or the united states they're like
wait that's a pretty big area
exactly so that gives you a sense of
like how fast you're going i think about
like you think about like a 747 yeah
that's fast that's 500 miles
per hour when you're up there you're
going 14 000 kilometers
per second so it's just like the speeds
in orbit i think sometimes they're like
hard to comprehend because like you
can't actually go that fast on earth
like if you're going that fast on earth
you
melt basically instantaneously the only
reason you can go that fast up there is
because you're in vacuum
and so if you miss even by a little bit
and it's like kind of hard with like
that rocket
people are just using radar to try to
figure out where the hell it was because
like there's a little bit of atmosphere
up there
and so the drag and how you hit it like
can just like
buff it around that rocket and so that's
why i was really hard part of what we're
doing is we're coming in hot and fast on
purpose
so that little atmosphere that's up high
doesn't sort of affect our path and we
can actually much more precisely say hey
faa we're going to come down like right
here and we're going to make sure that
there's no humans around and like
not going to hit anybody do you want to
land uh on land or
in the ocean it is much simpler
engineering problem to land on land and
so
when we when we fly we will be the first
commercial reentry vehicle to ever land
on land
um so dragon apollo all of those have
landed like on water
uh we would be the first ones to do it
on land why do they all want to land
in the ocean or spacex basically lands
on like a drone ship spacex's original
plan was actually to land on land so
uh the dragon was originally going to
have retro-propulsive boosters that
actually just landed it on a landing pad
on land um but um the qualification
process for getting nasa comfortable
with that
uh was basically going to take way too
long and so about maybe i think it was
like two years into the dragon program
they pivoted just being like screw it
we're just doing the apollo style
basically just like it's a lot
easier to just like you throw a
parachute up and then you just hit the
water
uh rather than like you know if you hit
ground going those speeds that actually
can be like you know harmful to the
astronauts and so
mostly it's like the reason we land on
water is just like it's an easier
engineering problem
splashdown's a lot easier than hard
ground yeah and it's funny because
they're
reusable rocket lands like oh the land
thing there's like regulation stuff why
don't we just create a drone
a drone ship and then we'll just use
that to land on like that's wild yeah i
mean that was part of the reason they
did the drone ship too was just like you
know it makes it a lot easier for
testing you don't have to clear
everything
like it's in the middle of the ocean
like there's no risk of like yeah the
rocket blows up whatever there's nobody
around
uh but over time spacex does want to get
more consistent and they do it
occasionally right when they have enough
fuel
um they've gotten the faa comfortable
now with like landing the rockets on
land
uh but for sure i'm sure in the long
term they're thinking about okay how do
we eventually make it so that like
when we're flying humans they also land
on land because like the seaports are
kind of a pain in the ass
is the idea that uh spacex you guys
whoever else
uh these rocks are gonna take off like
every 10 minutes yeah i mean with varda
the initial product that we're going
after if we were to eventually satisfy
the entire market that we're going after
we would have multiple of our reentry
capsules coming down per day and we
would be buying a spacex
rocket every other day and that's just
us and so there's a world where
uh you know spacex between you know
varda and all the other companies that
are coming up are literally
launching a rocket multiple times a day
and like we're not talking about that
being like you know a decade away we're
talking about that being like
you know this year they launched so far
already uh 28 rockets
so it means they're on track for you
know doing on the order of like 50 or
60.
um and so we're already talking about
like we're already at one a week
and like three years ago we were at like
one a month and so you know you
extrapolated that out in another three
years
um it wouldn't be surprising if there's
like a spacex rocket launch basically
every other day and another three years
after that multiple a day
yeah when you think about the cost so
you take your device you want to get it
up to space
and then get it back is that uh you said
i think the device itself is like 100k
and then the whole round trip was like
two three million dollars or
how was the economics yeah um so the way
you can kind of think about it
launch costs uh basically five thousand
dollars a kilogram today for like spacex
okay um and so when we think about it we
think about okay how much of
our entire so i mentioned that whole
thing the satellite the factory the
re-entry
how much of that is actually the useful
raw materials right because like that's
what we're really getting paid for
um in our early missions it'll probably
more look like five percent of the
entire thing
is going to be uh the useful raw
materials part of why eventually we want
to
uh leave the factory up there and dock
with the raw materials is it makes it to
the rather than being five percent it's
actually like 50 percent
because then we're just bringing up a
bunch of raw materials document the
factory and then taking them back down
um and so the way that i think about it
is sort of like the net cost of launch
for the raw materials
the first time is if it's five percent
it's basically well okay you're
basically paying 20 x the launch cost
rather than 5 000 it's like a thousand
dollars per kilogram
to get up there but once it's 50 of the
actual payload
then it's only ten thousand dollars per
kilogram of the actual raw materials
to get it up there and so that's kind of
the economics but then when you think
about it of like
okay well how many very useful materials
are there that you could sell for more
than a hundred thousand dollars a
kilogram
turns out if you look at semiconductors
and fiber optics and human organs and
things like that
most of those things if you wear it on a
per kilo basis they actually sell for a
lot more than that and so that was
basically what i was tracking in the
back of my head i had been thinking
about space manufacturing
for like a decade it just didn't work if
it was a hundred thousand dollars a
kilogram
because again that net cost of taking
things to launch was like millions of
dollars a kilogram
there's not many materials that sell for
millions of dollars a kilogram but
there's a lot of things that sell for
hundreds of thousands
so really the equation it seems like is
what's the cost of the raw goods
what's the cost of getting there
manufacturing getting back and
if you add up those two costs if you can
sell it for two three times that
whatever you bring back then you've got
a business that's literally what we
get kept up at night all night every
single day we're in the midst of digging
into this right now
all right and then uh really this idea
of like a reusable factory is really
what you're building
right and so it's it uh right now you've
got to set it up all connected but the
ideal thing is like literally there's a
factory there and you're just bringing
the input of materials there's some
process that happens and then there's
the output you bring it back
exactly exactly that makes the economics
a lot better because like right now each
time we're paying for the factory with
each mission that we send up
uh but the factory once the re-entry
module leaves that thing just
unfortunately burns up in the atmosphere
because it doesn't have a heat shield
and all the things you need to bring it
back down
but over time we'll just have factories
up there and we'll start off with one
and then we'll start off with two and
then ten and then like the thing that
gets me really excited about fart is
again we scale based off of commercial
markets the size
on earth rather than just pure
government dollars and so
if you track that exponential equation
of like once you need one factory and
then 10 factories 100 factories
you're talking about you know i think it
wouldn't be totally unrealistic to say
that
by the end of the decade we have
something that is bigger than 10 times
the size of the entire international
space station
that is just our factories that are all
connected together and then that also
makes it much more economical for a long
time they'll be purely robotic
but once you have something that large
it's actually not that expensive to them
be like okay well why don't we add a
human-compatible
uh you know module to it and then it
gets a lot easier to think about okay
actually having permanent humans
stationed up there on the factory uh
because you know it turns out
um it's actually a lot easier to get to
space than it is to build a robotic arm
that's as dexterous as a human is
when you think about this uh
you're going really really fast after a
massive market
one of the things that uh i noticed you
do i've seen uh keith roboy
on the open door um or i'm sorry open
store
uh deck he recently had is the number of
days
since you started and i don't know where
this came from but i've now noticed on
multiple people doing it uh why do you
guys do that why do you track how many
days it's been and then i also notice
that you have a countdown clock to
i guess the first launch so walk me
through kind of the timeline thought
process and why so obsessive about those
timelines
yeah it actually started with one of our
portfolio companies uh ramp um and i
think part of like their you know
culture and why they've done so well is
because they're so obsessive on days
like it was actually that the first
board meeting
i think it was like day 59 of like you
know ramp's life where keith and i went
to that first board meeting and it was
literally like the first thing that you
see in the deck
and keith and i just both turned to each
other we're like this is just [ __ ]
brilliant like this is the best way
to institute an ethos because at the end
of the day the thing that is always
difficult about startups
is early on it's easy to move super fast
when you're like six people in a room
you all can communicate really easy et
cetera once you become 600 all of a
sudden just decisions start to slow down
things start to slow down
and so in some ways you can almost
always predict how successful startup is
going to be
just off of how fast they move and this
is just like a really simple cultural
way of enforcing very fast movement
because when you're measuring things on
the order of days then it's a great like
you know i sometimes joke like you know
we have like a big deadline at varda for
example like that's like you know this
monday and i think today is like
whatever thursday
thursday to monday pre-varda felt like a
you know a snap in time
versus now with like the vardama
mentality it's like oh yeah thursday to
monday that's
like a month like i have plenty of time
to like you know all the things that we
need to do like
we'll have like six meetings between now
and then just discuss all the progress
like saturday and sunday everybody's
gonna be like totally online and so i
think it just like you know forces this
just mentality there's like extreme
speed
and then also it's even more relevant in
the world of like space stuff because
there are these just like
such clear delineations of like you know
a software company you like you do have
like launch days but like in a space
company you have like
launch days like you know those are
clear delineation and like marker in the
company's life
um and so yeah it started there and then
it's i feel like it is kind of spreading
amongst other founders that i know that
are also now starting to be obsessive
about it
but yeah every single all hands uh you
know at varda every single monday
morning we start off with like you know
it is day
xyz this number of days till launch uh
you know where you know whatever 15
of the way you know to our first launch
why is all hands on monday and most
companies in
silicon valley have done them friday
people can ask questions it's kind of a
kumbaya whatever
uh calling it in all hands and doing it
on monday seems more like a
kickoff meeting for the week or what is
that yeah it's funny um
you know i'm not the ceo of varda and
uh the ceo comes from spacex and a lot
of the early engineers come from spacex
uh so through them i've got to learn a
lot about sort of like you know uh i'd
say you know let's say
60 to 70 of our culture is kind of like
spacex culture
um and so there's just less of this like
there's so many things that i really
love about it one
like i walked into the factory one day
and there was like a 70-foot american
flag hanging in the factory and i was
like
this is amazing like in the san
francisco bay area being patriotic is
actually like somehow a polarizing topic
versus something about you're when
you're working in the world of aerospace
it's by default patriotic and who's
asking is like i love that i didn't
like ask for this at all and i was like
who did this in like a couple of
engineers were like yeah you got drunk
last night got a big ladder ordered this
off amazon and like you know immediately
and solid i was like this is
i love that part of the culture and the
second is there's just less of like a
culture around like
i don't know there's not this like yeah
all hands need to like ask questions
feel like my feelings get padded et
cetera it's just like
mondays we start it's like this is what
we gotta do like you know everybody like
checks in like yes this is what we're
doing it's like definitely like a
kickoff meeting and then fridays it's
like no there's no questions like you
have a question email the ceo he doesn't
have time to like
sit around and have everybody like you
know have a kumbaya moment like there's
no time for [ __ ] kumbaya
like email did you get the thing done
that you said you were gonna get done on
monday
and then we rinse and repeat the next
week and so yeah i like that style
are there free snacks uh we're limited
um yeah definitely closer to like you
know apple culture of uh you know no
free lunches
we do actually do free lunches but hey
guys what's going on before we continue
with this awesome episode i want to
quickly talk about our sponsor kraken
for the last 10 years kraken has built
one of the best platforms to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies online
they've got a brand new mobile app the
kraken app today you can go on and buy
bitcoin
or up to 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world
and you can do that on the go 24 7.
all you have to do is simply download
the app connect your bank account
and you can get started investing with
as little as 10 dollars
it only takes a minute to get started
with the new kraken app you'll have your
portfolio
in your pocket you can track your
portfolio see who the winners and losers
are every day
track your favorite project or just
simply look at the trading volume for
your favorite assets
it has all the features you need without
any of the complexity
it's simply the best place to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies
so go to kraken.com bang bang to learn
more
or go to your favorite app store and
simply search the word kraken and you
can download the mobile app there
crackit's been a long time supporter of
this show
so to say thanks it would mean the world
to me if you would go and download their
new mobile app
all right let's get back into this
episode i hope you're enjoying this one
you work at founders fun
and spend majority of your time
investing so varda is a big piece of
what you're focused on now but you do
spend a lot of time investing
uh i feel like everyone at founders fund
is red-pilled
like like just everyone has uh unique
views
uh they say what they want uh and what
they mean um
is it self-selection or is there
something going on or is there something
in the water at founders fund that
uh gets everyone kind of a lot of times
not even necessarily agreeing with each
other but just
having the confidence courage and
conviction to say what they actually
believe
yeah i mean i'll front run this by
saying also i think you'd be surprised
that probably i mean i don't want to put
an exact number on it but i'd probably
guess like 60 to 70 percent of the
investment team in the last election
like
almost certainly voted biden um and so
there's
for sure some amount of like red pilling
but i don't think that also necessarily
correlates with like
people's exact underlying politics
because there is actually a wide array
of politics for sure maybe certain
people on the team are a little bit like
you know louder than others and so
you might think that we're like all
biased in one direction but actually the
entire team might say is
quite you know diverse in terms of
politics and you know yeah very willing
to
be you know sort of very upfront about
that and it's absolutely sort of like
self-selection both in terms of like
when we interview people there is sort
of just like that does the person
fit the like founders fun ethos which is
just like are they very comfortable
being themselves being actually quite
divisive like i in some ways like
love our team in that very willing to
like disagree with each other both
publicly online right you've seen keith
and i even like get into arguments
online
but then just imagine that like if we're
like shielding a little bit externally
internally it's like you know people
will yeah it is full-time war at all
times right
uh but i really like that because it
forces like i said like intellectual
honesty where it's like it doesn't feel
like there's any politics at founders
fund like everything is just like
very intellectually open and honest and
like can be very disagreeable and there
can be people that have like you know
really significant arguments for
extended periods of time
but at least it's sort of like out in
the open and i think it is
self-selecting both in terms of
people that want to choose to work in
that environment but then also i feel
like during the interview process we're
like man is this person gonna like you
know survive the like intellectual
battlefield of founders fund yeah and so
uh when somebody comes in new or
somebody who's been there for a while uh
let's use founder fun as an example but
i think there's there's other firms that
have some of these
dynamics as well uh you've got very well
known people right that are
uh participating in the investment
process uh you've got kind of
legacy investments legacy lps legacy
um kind of reputation all this stuff and
then you've got this like
zero [ __ ] like everyone say what you
want and let's kind of have that of
attrition of ideas etc
how does that work in terms of making
investment decisions is it just like hey
delhi and here's a pot of money like go
invest it and like come back and tell us
what you did
or is there like no we all have to vote
and everyone has to agree or like like
how do you think through that and what
do you like and not like about the
process
yeah um so i'd say in the grand scheme
of silicon valley there's like sort of a
bell curve of types of firms i call them
like consensus-based investing and like
conviction-based investing
and both coastal vendors where i worked
prior to founder's fund and founders
fund i would describe as like on the
extreme end of conviction-based
investing
i.e if one person really really loves
and is like pounding on the table
like the thing sort of like gets done
for sure there's like a
amount of rope that is given to you
right like if uh if peter is pounding on
the table that is like a larger check
than like if deleon is pounding on the
table obviously uh
i thought it was the opposite that's
funny okay i learned everything
something new every day
um but like at least there's that
opportunity to sort of like pound on the
table
um and then what i like about founders
fund is uh cyan banister actually did an
interview on this maybe like you know a
year and a half or like two years ago
and so we actually like relatively
publicly share this but we actually just
like a very strict and regimented you
know process
around how investments get made but
we're actually not very strict and
regimented on
how to go through that process that
makes sense like as an investor so like
basically from like zero to 1.5 million
any two people in the team
basically thumbs up 1.5 to 5 it
basically becomes like three people
five to 10 becomes four people 10 to 35
people 30 and above six people and so
basically
as the checks get larger and larger you
need basically a thumbs up but
the thumbs up is closer to like you kind
of need like
let's say for the six people you know
are the super large checks
it's more like you need like three
people to be really enthusiastic
and three people that are more like it's
not a no i like i don't think this is a
bad idea
not like i'm also as equally like
pounding on the table as you are and so
for sure there are times
like i've seen keith like basically say
like i wouldn't do this investment but
i'm giving you my thumbs up to be clear
because like i don't think it's like a
bad investment i just wouldn't
necessarily do it
and i'm assuming some of that is like uh
let's say you really understand space
and let's say that keith i
actually don't know what how uh into
space he is but let's just say he he
didn't understand anything about space
if you could make the argument say hey i
want to do the space investment he's
like oh i don't really know that much
about space but like yeah that makes
sense to me okay i'll give you the
thumbs up but like i'm not gonna go
pound the table because i don't i'm not
an expert in space
for sure that's partially why like
you'll see it even in my portfolio i
kind of say that like
i feel like there's like two or three
different parts of my portfolio there's
like a third that's like the pure space
stuff
there's a third that i kind of describe
like kind of space-ish stuff but it's on
earth like whether it's like robotics or
industrial automation or it's like still
kind of like hard tech
and there's like a third of the stuff
that i do that it's like i literally
just say like [ __ ] that i learned from
keith
and partially because it's like it's
easier for me to like work through the
investment
process when like i'm investing into a
financial services thing like you know
ramp for example
because i know that keith will also
understand it really well and we can
work on it together and
then the two of us are like hey here's
the financial services thing both keith
and deleon are excited we really want to
do this
it's like actually you know quite easy
to get the deal done versus let's say
you know in the world of space
there's like less people on the team
that understand the space stuff it's
really like scott nolan and i are the
only ones
and so at some point like it's kind of
hard for other people on the team to
really give a super strong feedback
and that also makes it so that it's like
a little bit less likely that we'll take
a super super big swing
um you know in the world of space like
our you know interest or willingness to
take a 50 million dollar check into a
space thing
probably less likely like you know we
did recently invest a lot of money into
spacex but at a relatively late stage
lots of revenue starlink was going
online and so it's like easier to
understand now there's also like revenue
flowing in like numbers and so more of
the team got that
um but yeah so there's definitely like
domain areas of expertise and then what
i really like about founders fund
especially in comparison to most firms
most firms are not super willing to give
a lot of rope to junior investors like
they're pretty restrictive you really
can only uh you know report to one
particular person or they really limit
your sectors
founders fund we sometimes describe it
as like almost like the blockchain of
like you know investing where it's just
like
we don't have partner meetings we don't
meet up on any like regular basis
everybody kind of goes off and like does
their own thing
and like the way that keith runs his
investment process versus i run it
versus like you know brian or peter
are like wildly different at the end of
the day you get to get that same outcome
of like the votes
but like for example if i'm working on
like a space thing i might like go first
go to scott and then maybe rope in one
other person and then one other person
versus maybe if it's like something that
i know a lot of the team understands
i'll have it meet four people at once
right it's kind of up to you how you
want to take a founder through that
process as long as you do eventually get
to that very specific like set of those
so there's no monday meeting there's not
none of that
yeah there's no like we never have a
like you know basically every other firm
in silicon valley has like a monday
meeting
where like they have companies come in
and present to like the entire
partnership
um we almost never actually the only
time that we ever have full sort of
partner presentations
is actually only for incubations
initially enough partially because it's
just like hey this is our company let's
all meet and like see how things are
going
but we never do that for external
companies hereticon
is uh i think the best manifestation of
everything you just described is kind of
internal
then you guys are willing to put like a
stamp on and say like no this is
actually what we believe like we believe
we should go talk to people who everyone
else thinks
you know aren't worth talking to or
whatever like there's this conference
and i don't actually know how much of
this is like
founders fun backed versus like people
at founders fun
are helping to organize it but like talk
a little bit just about the public
component because there's almost this
element of like
uh there's lots of trolls there's lots
of like kind of the woke crowd and like
all this stuff that i think
most people now are just kind of saying
like look there's things that
legitimately our society needs to
improve and then there's like all the
virtue signaling stuff that's just like
a waste of time
uh it almost feels like you guys are
trolling the
trolls right to some degree and like
saying like look like you guys are being
ridiculous so like okay cool we'll just
ratchet it up and we'll be more
ridiculous on the other side
and uh that's not something that most
venture funds do so like
explain kind of your viewpoint of that
yeah i mean it's been interesting to see
you know obviously i've only been a part
of founder's fund for the past you know
whatever two and a half years now uh but
the firm's like let's say
both public viewpoints and the way that
it's presented has
shifted as sort of like the media
landscape has shifted as well right so
if you think about like you know 2010
publishing the manifesto you know we
wanted flying cars instead we got 140
characters
the brand was much more the firm but
that was sort of the ethos at the time
right this was pre-twitter this was
pretty sort of individual creators being
as much of a thing
institutions were the brands but now
over the past decade right
things have shifted like you know uh
people are much more interested in
talking to the ceo
of tesla they don't want to hear from
the tesla brand account on twitter right
and so i feel like we've just sort of
embodied that same thing which is like
you know it probably flipped and you
know honestly maybe when keith and i
joined we're all suddenly okay the like
core
founders fun twitter account was not as
much of like the voice anymore it was
now all the individuals that are
at founders fund that represent like the
like online voice
and what i like is like which is much
more willing to you know
um unlike most other firms there's
almost and you'd have to really push the
bounds there's almost nothing that you
could like say on twitter that would get
you like fired at founders fund
and so people are willing to sort of be
much more intellectually honest with
their like core values
but then what i like about it is like we
follow up with it right uh when you know
people complain about oh they're coming
to miami and they're like xyz
not you know appreciating the locals
whatever and then it's like and then
we're actually like funding the largest
series a
in miami right we just back it up you
know with our actions and so
um i like that when we like discuss
these ideas it's not just like
just for sake of trolling the trolls
it's also because there's like i feel
like real substance behind it and i feel
like that's why people seem to
you know enjoy enjoy the votes it's like
i feel like most of the voices that i
feel like on twitter are either
packaged corporate like you can tell
like this went through compliance
committee to like get out
not super interesting you have like the
just true virtue of signaling like you
know talking about like you know social
justice
then you have like the like troll
accounts that are just like the memes
and like humor but there's no like
substance behind it versus i feel like
we do for sure do some amount of
trolling but i feel like there is like
substantive like when you read like you
know mike zlano's pirate wires he's
talking about like you know fundamental
like society issues right
uh in those and then we follow up with
that with like fundamental societal
investments right
i think like anderl being like the
perfect example of this of like we
believe that like
in order to maintain western society and
democracy
and allow individuals to have freedom
you need to invest in capabilities like
the future of warfare
and most vcs are like not even willing
to touch the idea of that like anything
that is like oh
military contractor government something
like that
complete unwillingness to you versus
like we've had phenomenal returns
between palantir spacex
anderle we've have anything like forged
a new type of company
that can do technologies that both
benefit the government a lot but then
also end up bending benefiting like the
end consumer
a lot solana is probably the best
example mike salas who were talking
about uh is probably one of the best
examples because
he can very expertly navigate like
complete [ __ ] posting and trolling on
twitter
to then you read pirate wires you're
like wait a minute like that was
actually very intelligent and like well
thought out and well articulated
and i think that's part of what makes
founders fun founders fun right it's
basically what you're saying is like the
ability no we can go [ __ ] post and troll
everyone and yell and scream and be
idiots on the internet just like
everybody else
but then oh by the way like we're
actually very thoughtful and we also can
put money to work and do the things that
we need
yeah i mean there's like team
discussions that we have and obviously
like you know peter being like the
epitome of this or just like
extremely intellectual broad raging
discussions right even like debating a
particular investment
there's a lot of times where it's like
in the framing of like this like
extremely large like i wouldn't say that
we're like super thesis driven but we
think about like
the macro environment and why this is an
important investment to get done and
sometimes we even debate like oh are we
investing in this just because we have
this macro bias
towards x y or z and we want this to
exist in the world and we're investing
this even though maybe it's not a top
tier founder
but it just like you know matches our
ethos right there's a lot of these i
think like
very you know interesting discussions
that we have and i think that is
definitely something that the team
optimizes for is like both somebody
that's capable of doing that but then
also like you know grabbing a drink at
the bar and like having fun like the
founders fun like offsides let me tell
you we're like
they're they're a fun time like i i
enjoy those quite a bit you know both
the intellectual discussions at dinner
but then
we're getting trashed after dinner all
right uh three people
that uh i want you to tell what you've
learned from them and then we'll move on
uh
one from peter one thing from keith and
then one pick somebody else on the team
that you're like i really learned a lot
from this person here's what it is
yeah i mean the peter um like single
nugget that i always think about and
this actually like kind of comes from uh
you know trey stevens who sort of says
that this is the same nugget that he
shares from him which is
both prioritize having very um
unique thoughts but also how difficult
it is to do so
like most of the time even like most the
ideas that i reiterate whether it's like
you know crazy out there space
manufacturing or
you know talking about you know why you
know spacex is like the aws
most stars aren't my ideas you know i
mean like they're almost certainly
something that i've read somewhere
pulled together
and it's like very rare that i'm like
coming up with like an actual
truly unique individual formulation and
doing that actually requires extremely
deep thought while also having very
broad-ranging intellectual curiosity
both in terms of the people that you
meet that you talk to you that you read
and
and so that's definitely i feel like the
thing that i both admire the most from
peter and
uh aspire to and i think that is
something that he does obviously he's
like yeah world class at
um but probably prioritizing that is
something that i feel like i've learned
the most and sorry who's the
keith um keith is probably like
that there is actually a science to
operating companies like i feel like you
know so i was his chief of staff for
you know basically almost two years a
year and eight months um
and you know watching him across all the
variety of companies that he's involved
in right whether it's you know open door
like proptech you know affirm
fintech consumer social all the types of
companies that he's done
at the end of the day building a company
is actually the same across all those
verticals
it all comes down to the people that
you're hiring the operating cadence that
you maintain the way that you set your
goals
the way that you communicate in the
company how you run interviews like
all these things actually like there's a
just
best way to do them and for sure you
like kind of need to adapt them right
any rule obviously needs to be broken to
like you know fit into your company
but like actually that they're all the
same thing and i feel like it took me
like you know i sometimes joke like the
way that i sort of learn from keith is
like
he has this like gigantic tree of
knowledge and
in some ways he probably couldn't even
describe that whole tree himself but
each time we meet one particular founder
in one particular situation
i get to watch him traverse that
particular branch and then i see that
branch
and then i see another branch the next
day and the next day and i feel like my
job and part of why i wrote this like
series of i think it was like six or
seven essays at the end of that sort of
like
two-year stint where i just tried to
distill like there were some things that
keith is in like a really good job of
like distilling over the course of
various like podcast interviews
um and for those i mostly just like
stole his previous frameworks but
there's one that i was like kind of
proud of which is like um
uh you know how to be in effect how to
interview executives effectively
that one was actually like keith had
never really talked about or written
down his framework for interviewing
executives but having watched him like
interview like
15 cfos and 15 vps of marketing and 15
like vps of sales i was like oh
there's actually a pattern to how you're
doing all of these and this pattern is
actually like quite useful like
framework to think through
but this isn't something that he had
even like thought about and i remember
like showing him the essays like
is this framework correct and he's like
reading he's like huh that is correct
like yes like i hadn't thought about
framing it this way but like yes this is
basically like the decision making
framework that i go through and so
um yeah i guess like the science of
operating is i feel like what i learned
from you yeah it's fascinating that
once you understand the science then you
just replicate it over and over and over
that's why he's had such success is like
the reason that keith is a successful
investor obviously there's some amount
of like reflexivity to it of like
when you've had such success the best
founders want to have you on their board
but then part of it is like i think and
people have different philosophies on
this some people are like vcs or useless
blah blah blah
but the reason the really really good
founders want to have keith on their
board is like those very very difficult
situations where even like the top tier
founders
can't quite figure it out on their own
keith has seen the situation knows how
to deal with it and like actually gives
you like
meaningful advice and like you can talk
to everybody from like you know tony
shui doordash to max rhodes at fair to
like literally any company that he's
involved in i will guarantee you that
they will say
there's at least 20 instances of really
critical moments in the path of the
company
where keith changed their mind on a
particular topic or candidate or like
something that was actually quite core
that actually ended up helping the
company become much much more successful
and is he perfect
no but he's right like 90 of the time
and so if you're disagreeing with keith
you've been over like a really good
reason you're disagreeing with keith
he one time i was getting coffee with
him and i said something i was like yeah
you're pretty good investor he goes
actually
i've averaged one unicorn every year
since i've been investing
yeah and i was like okay you're really
really good right like it was just
uh you when you start to actually put
data around it it's unbelievable
i mean i think 20 years 20 unicorns or
something yeah he had i think
eight ipos over the course of six months
last year from
whatever june 2020 to december 2020 it
was literally just you know
back to back to back every single one
and it's not even like oh he was like a
small angel track it's like no
airbnb he was the first investor he put
in a decent amount of money into that
seed round and then like brought it to
sequoia for them to do the seed
doordash seed round of doordash right
like you know there's like all these
companies that have been extremely great
ipos
it's like when you get to the like
eighth one down the list you don't even
think about it but it's like oh yeah i
wish
also one of the early angel investors in
wish right but that's not even like
something that either even like talks
about or most people like even realize
yeah well they only list the top four
right so like the rest just get
forgotten
uh all right i feel like we talked a
little bit about being red pilled uh i
feel like you got
orange peeled or or whatever you want to
call it uh with bitcoin and crypto for a
little bit
it seems like you had conversations with
a few folks you can say who they are if
you want
um and you start to go down and then you
kind of have like slowed your role a
little bit on kryptos so maybe just talk
about like
what your thoughts on crypto were before
how you started to get a little bit
interested in and then what you think
now
yeah i mean i said my first foray into
crypto was probably like 2013 or 14 like
definitely got convinced i was like cool
bitcoin is a store of value
and i definitely debated and like
invested some amount then and i was like
maybe i should just hold this for the
long term
then i was like i'm like 22. i'd prefer
to spend my money on like beer and like
startups and like just like kind of
enjoying life rather than like really
investing at the time
and so i kind of put it on the shelf for
a while and maybe held on to like one
bitcoin or something like that for a
while
um whole coiner yeah exactly one coin
exactly um and so yeah i kind of put it
on the shelf for a while then i'd watch
it and i'd like you know occasionally
catch up with friends and
um i have this friend arjun balaji you
know we've known each other i think
since yeah fall 2011 literally basically
since like you know freshman year of
college
um and so he's obviously gotten you know
very much into crypt i don't know
exactly when he started but most
recently he's now
you know uh one of the investment
partners at paradigm um
and so i've been watching crypto from
afar occasionally catching up to um you
know generally stuff out i was like you
know store value
still really feels like the only like i
don't know like what i call like
business use case like where i felt like
there really was something that like
made a sense for a business to use
um and then you know we were grabbing
you know lunch maybe like three or four
weeks ago
and i'd been kind of poking into d5 a
little bit but it was at lunch with him
that really convinced me that like
algorithmic liquidity pools were like
this aha moment for me where i was like
whoa there is actually like a second
um you know true business use case
because there is a long tail of assets
the example that i always like to give
uh you know i won't say who it is but
like i have a friend that is like now
working on this extremely uh interesting
startup
basically trying to like securitize um
uh musicians and artists basically like
future earnings
and create a way for that artist to
basically sell some of that you know
future cash flow
up front but then ideally also have a
market where people you know can trade
them along the way
and do that not only for all their
future cash flows but even down to like
particular albums
uh the problem is for creating liquidity
market for that you can't afford
to have like a trading desk behind that
right jane street's not going to invest
in some random joe schmoe you know r b
musician from chicago's you know trading
desk for his like album
but define liquidity pools felt like a
way i was like oh okay here's a way
where you could actually create
um you know an algorithmic uh you know
liquidity pool and real quick just so
for people who are listening who don't
understand what this is
basically there's an entire idea of
let's say there's a couple of different
assets
uh liquidity providers put the assets
into these pools uh
and then there's literally a
decentralized protocol in an automated
fashion that says dellion wants x asset
and he's willing to give y asset and
literally it takes y gives him x
uh and the different pools provide
various returns to liquidity providers
as a way to incentivize more or less
assets in the pool
and the way that it was sort of like
pitch to me which is slightly different
than how you pitched it which is part of
why i got maybe slightly unenthused with
it was that
let's say that this was actually let's
say you know kanye drops a new album and
there's a share price the way that like
typically share prices are generated is
like you actually have a
like market maker i somebody who's
finding buyers and finding sellers and
funding they're basically like middle
price
and then that's how the price gets
determined and i said the way that i was
pitched the liquidity pool was
instead there's just like as you buy a
share
and actually rather than getting given
to somebody else it actually gets put
into this like pool of money
the larger the pool of money goes
logarithmically the price of the stock
goes up so that each time you want to
buy an individual sort of new share
it gets more and more expensive until it
basically gets infinitely expensive at
the final share
and then the reverse happens is as
people are selling they just take their
money out of the pool
and then the price logarithmically goes
down and the price actually never
reaches zero because it just
keeps shrinking shrinking shrinking so
the liquidity pool also never really
reaches zero
in practice i basically started to play
around with this and there were some
parts that were disappointing where i
was like oh well i do kind of understand
yeah there needs to be a sort of
counter token let's say and i found that
some of the liquidity pools that i was
playing around with
it was more that they were like playing
around with the fact that there was
actually volatility on both sides of the
markets if you had like a
you know an ether uni swap liquidity
pool well the problem was like
it didn't really feel like i was trading
into one or the other is mostly like
dealing with the volatility of the two
assets now you can obviously fix that if
instead you had like a you know what i
understand to be like a stable coin
and then you know kanye's album on one
side great the stable coin should stay
stable
and therefore the like you know
volatility only comes from kanye's album
price basically like moving up and down
uh but after playing around with it for
a weekend i
purposely like you know i'm a relatively
decent software engineer
um you know started playing around with
it and it kind of started from scratch
honestly if i hadn't done the kyc from
coinbase it would have taken even longer
i did that obviously six years ago
um but like it literally took me like i
think almost like 36 hours from start to
finish from like
buying ether buying uni-swap to
eventually actually getting those into a
liquidity pool
and it was like obviously not continuous
36 hours but like waiting for one thing
waiting for
you know whatever you know gas prices
that day were super high and things were
taking forever blah blah
and even then just like understanding
like what is my lp position in this pool
and the fees that i'm generating from
like liquidity
anyways i came away from it being like
this is still probably a little closer
to darpanet days than it is like
ready for like google to get co-founded
and so i feel like my like net
conclusion was like
i'm not short crypto i'm just more like
i'm gonna probably put it on a shelf for
another two or three years wait for like
the true crypto believers to make it a
little bit more mass-market
and then i'm like great i'm ready to
like fund a company maybe in another two
or three years it almost feels like uh
i'm cheating because we talked a little
bit about this already um uh off air but
you see the light at the end of the
tunnel to some degree right it's like
okay cool like if this continues
progressing like there is going to be a
lot of value created here and
and uh there's bitcoin there's other
stuff whatever uh
right now though it's hard to use it the
user experiences the interfaces are
different
like it's just gonna be really really
hard to go build a multi-billion dollar
multi-uh you know tens of billions of
dollar company
based on that idea with that said
uh do you think at all about like that's
company right like a centralized entity
versus these protocols that get
created and like let's hold constant for
a second like uh there's just
some you know manipulation that goes on
or like you know dogecoin ends up being
you know 60 billion dollars i was like
ah
maybe right um but the protocol have
value like have you thought yet about
uh kind of protocols or market caps
versus like company evaluations and like
how you
how they uh are similar or different
yeah i mean somebody had a funny tweet
on this and i might not be able to like
remember the like exact wording
but it was basically like if you're
thinking about how you're going to make
a lot of money off your protocol it's
probably a company and it's not a
protocol
that's a great way to look at it because
if you look at smtp nobody made a lot of
money off of smtp or sms or all these
other protocols that like you know
people talk about
um and so i guess that's where you know
i agree there's maybe something like yes
you want to incentivize early adopters
of a protocol via token et cetera but
um i'm maybe more skeptical of the like
world of yeah
decentralized companies i think at the
end of the day like really great things
only happen when a small group of people
come together have an aligned vision and
like build it together
um and protocols don't necessarily
totally you know satisfy that
do you think that makes bitcoin an
outlier in terms of like this thing got
built with like millions of volunteers
on the internet or however you want to
describe it like is that because it's
uh vying to be money versus like a
productive decentralized entity
yeah i mean it's like store value feels
like something that's like yes that does
feel decentralized in some ways
like you wanted to be like that's part
of why gold is such a great store of
value is like
nobody like owns gold gold is just like
a material that is fully independent
versus with like decentralized liquidity
well you know if i'm kanye and i'm
listing my album somewhere
i'm probably only going to do that if
i've got like a support number to call
you know what i mean like they want
they still want a corporate entity as
like a part of that um i
i think it we're a ways away from people
being willing to like create such large
assets again why does airbnb go ipo in
the nasdaq and not in like some you know
crypto equivalent it's like there's
somebody to call at the end of the day
to like you know deal with these large
assets
sometimes think about when people talk
about like this is the thing that i was
like i was actually purchasing arjun you
know from paradigm really hard on this
i was like how does a crypto transaction
eventually happen where i buy a physical
asset like i buy a home
at the end of the day like it still
feels like mostly what happens today is
it gets converted into fiat and then
fiat is used to go like you know buy the
home
because it turns out like you know
people there's both regulations around
buying homes there's you know titles and
things like that
um and the world of like all of that
shifting fully to crypto
in some ways requires the government
buy-in and so you need the government to
somehow start to issue these tokens but
in a day there is a backing entity
behind us it's not like there's like
some
decentralized protocol for real estate
uh partially because it's like well okay
so if somebody like you know steals my
whatever
you know secret key and then literally
do they get to like steal my house and
is there literally like no retribution
for that like with bitcoin i get it
somebody steals your bitcoin there's no
retribution that's fine same thing kind
of you know honestly in the real world
there is at least some retribution for
gold like the us government will try to
like investigate on your behalf but man
if people can like steal my house if
they just get into my secret key
and the government's not going to help
me like that seem and that's the world
of like a decentralized protocol that
seems kind of tough and so i still think
there's going to be some amount of
centralization
uh speaking of houses last thing i want
to talk about is miami uh you have a
house here
um you are one of many people who came
to visit
uh i think kind of as like let me go
check this out let's see
um and then you're like no i'm actually
gonna move and i remember you dimmed me
and i was like wait is he kidding
like like no way he just got here like
three days ago and then you're like no
no like seriously like i'm doing it
so walk me back to you tweet while in
san francisco you get retweeted by the
mayor and he's like how can i help it's
this whole thing now
what's your perspective on the whole
miami thing and like your role in this
yeah i mean we originally started
debating like where would we open a
second office in like july 2020 because
keith was really looking to like leave
the bay area
and finally maybe like september october
we like settled in miami he like bought
the house decided to move
the entire time i was just like dude
like how is he going to be as like top
tier investor how's he going to win
really competitive series a's like
this in-person stuff really does matter
that's going to come rebounding back
like
it feels totally impossible and then in
december it was just like sitting there
and this is like in
deep in the groud of varda you know what
i mean like i've been working on like
basically pulling the company from
scratch dealing with all the
you know uh convincing the co-founders
that we should work on this equities
play it's business plan fundraising et
cetera it was like
it was rough doing that while also
trying to do my founders fun job at the
same time like i felt like i was working
crazy hours
the one thing that was keeping me sane
was i could go have outdoor dining at
the [ __ ] wild seed restaurant next to
my house it was like a nice way to like
cap the night
and i remember just seeing the like you
know announcement of like we're shutting
down outdoor dining and i was like
sitting on the can i was like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
there's no scientific evidence if
there's any outdoor spread why are they
doing this if anything's gonna make
things worse
because i guarantee you people have now
started to become accustomed to being
social outdoors now they're gonna all go
all indoors it's gonna be even worse
than if you just cap the outdoor dining
and so i said what i thought was like
very obviously a pithy tweet to my
followers because i've been tweeting
about like ant miami things for the past
like you know month and like arguing
with keith about it like publicly
and it was like oh [ __ ] it like what if
we just like picked up silicon valley
and like moved to miami so we don't have
to deal with like outdoor dining stuff
and then you know lo and behold like the
mayor quote tweeted it and he was like
you got to come visit like this went
viral blah blah and i was like dude like
i just started this company and like we
have 14 people that are starting like in
our la office on like whatever jan 19th
i don't have time to [ __ ] like think
about a miami trip but anyways varda
sort of got off the ground we got
everybody onboarded we had this first
you know whatever board meeting early
march
and like keith's birthday was like you
know second or third week of march and i
was like you know
maybe i could afford to go like visit
miami for a week go check it out i
remember talking to my girlfriend like
that sunday before we were
like there's no [ __ ] way we're moving
like varda's in la
like all my friends are in san francisco
keith's totally wrong about this thing
like there's no way
and then over the course of a week a
couple like you know cracks started to
appear in my argument like you know on
wednesday i remember like going
out to dinner with keith and just like
looking around the restaurant be like
jesus like this is like uh the deck uh
which is like this you know restaurant
that's actually like pretty close to
here
and i was like this is a more vibrant
and happy and like
laughing like lifestyle and vibe in this
restaurant
than like even like the best restaurant
and like choose your favorite evening
san francisco whatever you want new
years anything it is like less fun and
less happy than like how happy i feel
right now
i care a lot about being happy because i
think it does make you like work harder
and i found that in miami that i work a
lot harder
and then the following night i went to
this like uh tech party that you were
also at like whatever in march where i
just walked in the room and i remember
just being like oh my god
there are more top-tier vcs builders
like you know engineers founders
in this room than what i've seen in san
francisco for years san francisco used
to have these like very fun ostentatious
parties like i remember like 2014-15
going to these like crazy pool parties
in woodside you'd see like everybody all
these types of builders
and like it sounds kind of silly but i
actually do think those parties are
important
because like those spontaneous
interactions sometimes lead you know
somebody who maybe works in space to
talk with a d2c ecommerce thing and
turns out there's actually some sort of
collaboration
and like when those sort of parties
started to get canceled over the course
of like you know canceled culture in san
francisco
you just lost out on that and so people
didn't have these like spontaneous
interactions nearly as often
and i do think that's quite important
like i remember from that party in march
i knew that like six or seven
investments happened like multiple deals
got signed like a lot of things happened
from that party
and i walked in and i sort of like i
said it originally as a joke to a friend
but then the moment the words left my
mouth i was literally like i don't know
how the [ __ ] i'm getting on the return
flight to san francisco and the moment
that it hit and i said it like i had not
been thinking about it until that moment
and then i said it and i looked at my
friend i was like oh my god i'm moving
to [ __ ] miami
i was like i think i am and then nadia
by the way my girlfriend was having a
completely like parallel experience
where she had actually left
uh miami for two days to go to disney
world with all of her friends and i kind
of described her as like you know she's
much more like the
public intellectual writer researcher
like much more
you know creative than i am smarter much
smarter than i am you know she was
having this parallel experience where
one all of her like friends had already
moved to miami
and she just felt like her like creative
energy was so much more unlocked by
being in this place that was much more
intellectually diverse physically
diverse
so many more colors and beauty um than
she was seeing in san francisco
and so she had actually been having this
whole discussion with her friends that
she was driving back down from disney
world for like this dinner that we're
gonna have friday night together
where she was like oh my god i need to
have this like very serious conversation
with delian we're like i want to spend
more time in miami because i'm really
happier here and i'm enjoying it here
and i know he really loves san francisco
but like i really i can't go back to san
francisco i need to be like spending
more time here and she's like arrives to
dinner and it's like
dallian i think we should spend more
time in miami and i just like replied
was like i think she just moved to miami
she was like
what i was like i think we should just
move and i was literally like we
basically like didn't talk about it
after that we were like great we're
moving to miami that was like it that
was the extent of the discussion
then sunday morning we woke up took a
vesper around the city went to a couple
open houses
and basically like bought the like you
know second house that we visited we're
like great put in the offer the next
morning
and you know started planning the move
and that was the extent of it 48 hours
from you know deciding to uh
uh moving what was keith's reaction when
you told him
um he was at first i think like almost
like uh in disbelief that like it
happened
um but there was actually a sort of nice
text that i got where the actual moment
that i texted him
um that we got the offer accepted he
actually happened to be on a zoom call
uh with a like mutual friend of ours the
mutual friend said like that was like
the happiest he'd ever seen keith in a
long time
uh so it was nice to you know as i said
get that text i i
i feel like he really really stuck his
neck out there like put his reputation
online and said hey like this is real
and your story is very common
where even myself i came and i came
because i just wanted to get out of new
york for a weekend
right yep and then i was like wait this
is like weird like
i think it was uh mateo and alex from
eight sleep
uh steven from cameo keith like like
there was and i was like wait a minute
like there's way more people here than i
thought there were
and then we came back the next weekend
uh for a whole week
and i was like are we gonna do like you
you almost are like am i getting tricked
like like what's the cash exactly
and then the it's funny you say
happiness that's how i describe people i
say i'm a happier miami and that
encompasses a whole bunch of different
things
uh i don't know if it's the sun if it's
the people if it's just the environment
if it's the diversity of
you know kind of this is like the
capital of south america some people
describe it
whatever it is i do feel like people are
happier and
uh there's higher energy and some people
look at that from a work perspective and
say i work harder some people just look
at like it's a higher quality of life
yeah i mean for me i'm like all i care
about is you know my number one goal in
life is i want to be one of the best
investors of all time and i want to
build
a lot of very big space companies over
the course of my career and
when i'm happier i just work harder and
so i just i can't imagine like ever
deep prioritizing that and like moving
somewhere else more than miami because
she's like there's no [ __ ] way
i like work harder here than i did in
san francisco moving back would involve
like compromising my productivity
and i have like zero willingness to do
so and then yeah also it turns out like
the weekend's a lot more fun and then
part of the reason i'm also much more
productive is like
i'll work a 12-hour day and then like
you know in san francisco if it was 9pm
it's like
you're going home all the restaurants
are closed you're uber eating like some
shitty burrito and like you're watching
netflix with like your girlfriend
where she's here at 9pm it's like i can
go to mila i can have a quick like one
hour meal
and by the way there's like fire dancers
a dj i'm having a great [ __ ] time and
like what i've realized
is like this took me a while to figure
out how to articulate like why it was so
refreshing
is because when you're in that like
burrito netflix watching mode in san
francisco
it's kind of still like the same delion
that was like the work delia like it's
not like change
versus 15 minutes or so into mila like
for sure the first 15 minutes i'm still
kind of
like in work mode and then at some point
you just like have so many people
laughing around you and the lounge music
and the fire dancers
that about like 20 or 30 minutes in you
just kind of transform into like what i
call like
vacation dahlian and it's like you're
happier and you're excited and all the
stress and like the [ __ ] you have to
deal with all day like totally melt away
and just be able to sort of have that
like literally like daily reset of like
having everything just totally melt away
allows me to like then approach the next
day i feel like a much fresher clearer
mind
and like work super hard again everyone
in san francisco knows the tech industry
is there
and everyone's in tech and therefore
like you go to the bar
everyone should talk about work stuff
right uh especially if you're public on
twitter like if somebody sees you at the
bar like hey let's talk about this oh
space
founder fun whatever i gotta start up
let me pitch you like all like all the
craziness
here nobody gives a [ __ ] exactly like
literally there's not a person in mila
who gives a
[ __ ] about the tech industry they're
literally here from every industry
all different cities uh some people from
the united states not from the united
states whatever like there's there have
a good time
and i think that's what you're kind of
getting at is like you don't feel like
everywhere you go
from the coffee shop where you see all
the vcs uh and founders to then
work to then you go to a restaurant and
then you go home and you do it all over
again like it's just you just
are seeing the same people that are in
the same industry over and over and over
again san francisco and miami's
completely different there's such a
melting pot here in so many different
ways right like i love the fact that you
have people that are like
barry stern like one of the best real
estate investors operators of like all
time
you have thomas bravo one of the best pe
firms of all time you have like antonio
gracias one of the best deep tech
investors of
all time and you have keith threat boy
one of the best like fintech healthcare
attack like
you know more consumer venture investors
of all time those never were ever like
it was impossible to get all four of
those types of people in one room
anywhere in the world because like the
likelihood of them actually coordinating
travel or going to the same conference
is quite low
where's in miami that happens all the
time so you both have this like
intellectual melting pot but then
obviously also you have the like
cultural
like diverse melting pot like what i
love about miami is like nobody's
talking about race
because there's just so many different
people from so many different types like
why that like nobody
it's not even ridiculous to even like
talk about it versus go i went back to
like san francisco this past weekend
like a friend's birthday and i remember
it was like shocking me like i walked
down chestnut street literally for like
five minutes
and like the thing that just kept going
through my head i was like there are so
many [ __ ] white people here
and i never appreciated it until like
now living in miami
where like now it just feels like so
jarring where i'm like oh my god
i just like my olive skin does not
[ __ ] fit in here and now i get why i
feel so much more relaxed in a city of
immigrants that is much closer weather
to bulgarian weather
where like nobody asks me who i am where
i'm from et cetera because it doesn't
[ __ ] matter everybody's got a weird
name and has a weird accent and like has
you know weird colored skin
if it doesn't [ __ ] matter nobody's
gonna ask you about it nobody's gonna
judge you based off it
versus san francisco they're all [ __ ]
looking the same and they're the ones
that are constantly talking about like
racial politics
critical race theory and it's like the
only reason you guys are talking about
that is you'll [ __ ] look the same
i wish i had a microphone you could drop
all right i got three questions before i
let you go you could ask me one uh most
important book you've ever read
oh man
probably god i just love
i mean i don't know if it's like
important and that it changed me but i
just love seven eves by neil stevenson
it's about this uh basically this like
they call it like a critical event where
basically
um uh what is probably like a small
amount of antimatter passes through the
moon
causes the moon to start breaking up and
then basically causes like an armageddon
type situation
where eventually a bunch of meteorites
from that basically collision two years
later
are gonna rain down on the moon it's
just like this amazing story of just
like
the whole like you know world um having
to
coalesce around oh my god the earth is
ending we have two years to figure out a
ton of different interesting space
technologies and figure out how to make
ourselves
a space faring uh you know civilization
but i like it because it's like written
in a very like hard science very
realistic way
based off of like today's technologies
like it's not written with some like
crazy we have
nuclear whatever you know starships like
it's like if we like literally today had
to figure this [ __ ] out and figure out
how to like you know make it so the
entire human race could survive off
earth
like what would we do basically for the
next two years um and i always think
about that because i'm like that's
almost like the pace that i want varda
operating at it's like if we don't
[ __ ] make varda work and like make
ourselves a multi-planetary organization
like
you know we could actually end up in the
scenario where you know an asteroid
comes and kills us all
that's very deep all right eight sleep
uh i sleep on the thermo-regulated bed
i'm assuming you do as well
what's your sleep schedule um i'm pretty
diligent about it i'd say it's probably
like you know
in bed at like 10 30 10 45 asleep by
basically like 11
11 15. um i have i think at this point i
was counting it up i think it's like six
eight sleeps uh in my life so i have one
that sits in the varda office in la so
every time i fly there i go directly to
the office pick it up and then i go
install it at the hotel room that i'm at
there's not enough hotel rooms right now
with eight sleeps near the office i have
two in my parents house in utah um and
then two
uh you know here in miami so you're
you're a believer
yeah i'm 100 a believer i actually slept
on the very first eight sleep
outside of the founders it was like a
jumble of wires some sketchy looking
pomp
it woke me up a couple times because it
was like you know way too cold but
did you think you like peed in the bed
or something yeah exactly exactly there
were a lot of uh
there was some rough moments the first
couple years of prototyping yeah but
it's great i love it
uh aliens believer or non-believer
that's a good question
i don't know if i believe that the ufo
stuff that we're seeing is caused by
aliens but i for sure think that there
are sentient aliens
that are probably much closer to us
almost certainly for sure in the milky
way and also much closer to us than
probably we expect
uh so i agree difference between ufos
and aliens the odds that the ufos are
just things that we haven't identified
or figured out yet but not aliens
probably pretty high uh if they're in
the milky way
or closer than we think do you think in
our lifetimes we'll be able to
communicate even from afar or like
recognize
or do you think it's something where
they're probably out there but it's just
the technology barrier's too big and we
won't be able to actually find them
i don't think in our lifetime but i mean
yeah
when you're doing these far up
projections kind of hard but next 300
years
absolutely if you like you know just
track the pace of our exponential
progress in space
in terms of just like sphere of
influence and how quickly humanity can
grow
and just say okay imagine that bubble
just continues to expand for sure over
the next 300 years almost certainly at
some point that bubble will get large
enough where we will eventually interact
with a uh with another
alien species all right you could ask me
one question to finish up what you got
for me okay
uh what is your favorite part about
dating somebody that's bulgarian
or sorry married married to somebody
that's bulgarian
and maybe least favorite as well yeah
but has people guarantee specifically
can't
you be like pelina specifically yeah due
to the fact that she's bulgarian i think
well there's the bulgarian experience
that's what i'll call it so uh there's
this element of like
toughness which um i actually can't
separate is it just like the immigrant
element of it
versus like the bulgarian specific
element of it but there's
uh many situations where uh you just
kind of
like you you didn't complain you didn't
whatever
like just the way that you handle that
situation is very very different
than almost any other person i know that
in that situation
uh and that that toughness to me has to
be from the
experience whether it's immigrant or
bulgaria together
and one of the funniest things i think
of in terms of i've been a bulgarian now
i think three or four times i know
enough words to be dangerous to like
tell her mother like i
or her grandmother i love her and she's
beautiful and like you know whatever
right
uh but planta's father
lived through the hype and
hyperinflation in bulgaria uh
literally at one point his salary ended
up being the clone like 30 cents a month
and so he just like stopped going to
work
yeah and talking to him i get reminded
all the time of the american ideals and
like the ethos
and the freedom and like democracy and
capitalism like all the things that
sound so stupid like
oh why do you care about that stuff like
no go talk to somebody who lived through
communism like they literally will be
like that sucked this is way better
exactly and so like polina has an
element to it too where
uh she's not as vocal about it but like
there's you know a lot of stuff happened
over the last year so
she's just like man there's a lot of
complaining going on but like uh
i came from a country like that wasn't
so cool compared to this country it's
kind of pretty cool
uh and so i think like you just get that
constant reminder of like
hey there's a lot of things that can be
improved but we got it pretty good right
now
yeah i think that's partially why i love
miami so much it's like it's a bunch of
people that all hate communism like i
remember
i was just like political event like
this like old cuban guy comes up to me
he's probably like 55 or 60 and he's
like
it's like you know why are you here at
this event like why do you like it so
much and he was like
well i grew up in bulgaria and then he
caught me off he's like that's all you
got to say
and i was like okay yep that's it it's
crazy because um i
i do think that there there's this uh
element of like america was the upstart
america was the challenger and we did
such a great job and we ascended to this
position of power and frankly
privilege right in the world of just
like i was born in the united states and
i never had to worry about
hyperinflation i never had to worry
about communism never had to worry about
this stuff
and also we were indoctrinated into like
well democracy is good like yeah no [ __ ]
right
like okay capitalism whatever but
there's a different
appreciation for when you come from a
place that doesn't have it and now you
have it right like you almost
uh you get to understand what the other
side looks like versus like reading it
in a book
and so just like there is this element
of many immigrants that have experienced
that they just they understand
that's why we're so fearful of like you
know when you start to see things that
like diverge away from what we believe
to be like democratic capitalism i feel
like there's much more of a like an
averse reaction to that as an immigrant
versus i feel like some of my friends
that are born and raised here have
become somewhat complacent with the idea
of like
oh well maybe we can do like universal
xyz you know benefit and just pay
everybody to not work xyz and like
all the people that have come from there
you're like no no no no we know how this
starts and where this game ends
like no [ __ ] way are we going down
that path
we're not gonna go there uh where can we
send people to find more about varda
founders fund or you on the internet um
so for varda it's just varda.com so
pretty easy we put up a you know a bunch
of interesting stuff we'll have a new
website coming pretty soon
uh for myself probably my twitter handle
at zabolgar z-e-b-u-l-g-a-r
uh i'm in founder's fund probably
foundersfon.com and the founder's fund
handle at founders fund
awesome man thank you we'll do this
again absolutely thanks pomp